[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 132 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mach Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warwick Melanie how
are you doing today I'm doing good mark
how are you I'm very very well good so
this week mark we are going to be
talking with Thaddius from hand tucked
out of Brazil we talked about the fact
that they've built a product that
translates written and spoken Portuguese
into Brazilian sign language which is
really cool yes really cool I definitely
very much enjoyed that interview but as
always before we get into the interview
we will talk about the cool things the
week as well as at the end of the
interview we will talk about our
question of the week and one question we
have which is coming from one of our
colleagues is what does it go developer
need to know about GCP what do they need
to know something special we will find
out so stay tuned but before we get into
all of that as always cool things of the
week and one of the cool things of the
week we were advertising for next yes we
were we were videotaped in mid ending of
a podcast sort of yep and yeah we've got
a funny little video that's out there
that you can check out three questions
with a Googler if you wanted to know
things about us yeah if you want to know
what are some of our favorite items on
our desks pretty much check out that
video yeah so we'll include that link in
our show notes as always awesome
so we also announced a new region so GCP
arrives in the Nordics for the new
region in finland doing a really good
job of opening up new regions all the
time yes and the regions always lead to
improvements in our latency
yeah that's Europe North one and it's
shown in the Netherlands Belgium London
and Frankfurt in Europe we also
announced that Google AI is going to be
in Ghana and so in the fall they're
opening up a center Research Center
specifically located in Accra Ghana I
think is the name so yeah it's just
pretty exciting and I know there's been
a lot of work in that region to train
and do training on AI and training on
digital training for machine learning
and other technical skills so this will
be wonderful to have that Research
Center set up in that region yeah
well also highlight we seem to be doing
a lot of stuff with with teammates
recently fellow developer advocate you
finger
has a book post about bigquery datasets
as he says it's specifically the big
data is great but getting your hands on
large datasets is no easy feat so he has
a list of bigquery data sets that you
might be interested in playing with he
shows you how to access them and I think
it's about 40 data sets so you don't
have to actually pay for the storage of
those sets you can get access to them
and do machine learning and other types
of projects we had oh there's lots of
cool stuff lots of stuff last week was
darker Khan we had a number of Googlers
who were there and speaking as began
different topics one of our fellow
teammates Michelle Casman who we had on
the podcast a few weeks Yaak talking
about data science so she did a demo at
docker con David Aaron check Aaron Jake
yeah
Aaron check ok so anyway they did a demo
they were showing docker with GCP and
they're showing TP use and one thing I
wanted to highlight that she gave a
shout out to on Twitter was that because
darker Khan supports child care at
conferences that enabled her to actually
be there and so you know other
conferences out there who are trying to
figure out how to increase their
diversity consider adding child care
that's super nice super super nice last
but not least it just want to highlight
that unite Berlin is on right now
probably just before we did this podcast
the keynote would have happened remember
to check that out I think you should
show a look alright mark it's time for
us to go and speak with Thaddius about
hand talk let's do it this week we have
with us that is Luz who is from hand
talk who's here to talk to us about what
hand talk does and how its using GCP
that is thanks for joining us thank you
that is can you tell us a little bit
about the company what does hand talk do
so I'm a founder and CTO I can't talk
which is a start-up based here in the
city of masao in Brazil which is in the
coasts and very warm weather and nice
beaches nice and I'm also a Google
developer expert in firebase hand talk
is a company that offer automatic sign
language interpretation solutions for
users and companies as well and we do
that through a friendly virtual traded
character named Hugo so how did you guys
come up with this company
ok so Harry talked him talk started when
in 2011 I
came back from Canada I was living in
Toronto for two years with my wife and
working under the effects industry
that's actually my background is in
computer graphics and digital
compositing and when I came back a
couple of friends invited me to help
with this project that we're working on
which is which was a prototype for a
demo day that we're gonna have here in
Masayo and the idea was to come up with
an app that would translate to sign
language using a virtual character and
they needed someone that had experience
with character design and 3d animation
to finish him off so that's how I
started how did the company decide to
work on from translating spoken and
written Portuguese into Brazilian sign
language this idea was a school project
actually from my co-founder and my
partner on now he's a CEO now he had
this idea for a very long time came up
with this product when he was in
university and he needed to do that to
come up with a marketing campaign for
the product so he thought of doing
something at the time which was using
desktop computers or notebooks and this
was a long time ago in 2004 even before
the iPhone so after that we thought that
this could work for mobile devices and
we did this demo for this contest here
this local contest in maceió and we won
the first prize everybody loves Hugo and
we use the money as seed investment you
open up the company and that's what
we've been working on ever since awesome
um can you tell us more about the
problem - like is the translation from
say Portuguese or even just written like
any sort of written language - sign
language is that kind of one-to-one or
how complicated is that okay so that's a
good question because it's not at all
one to one sign languages are languages
by themselves like proper languages they
are not signed English or signed
Portuguese they have a structure and
a grammar and morphology that's specific
to them so when we first started we
thought that the hardest part will be to
animator language because there are
quite a few signs in Brazilian sign
language I think it's over it's
estimated it's over 40,000 and we
thought it would be really hard to
animate a language but the actual hard
part is to restructure the grammar and
make it work as a different language so
it sounds like this is very similar to
say a translation between French and
English or like English and Portuguese
as much as it is you know like a spoken
language to a sign language exactly one
of the important things to notice is
that there are over 200 different sign
languages in the world today Brazilian
sign languages or libras how we call it
is the Brazilian official sign language
but in the US you guys use ASL and it's
important also to say that there is no
relationship between the oral language
of a country and the sign language that
they use ASL is used in Canada and
Mexico as well in some parts of Central
America Asia in Africa and ESL is
actually the the most popular sign
language in the world well in terms of
the app itself how can you access it how
is it used the app is free to use you
can find it on Google Play in Apple's
App Store and you can download it and if
you're interested in learning sign
language for now you can just type or
say whatever you want and Hugo will sign
it back to you we also have a couple of
sessions where you can get started with
sign language learning groups of signs
like fruits and dollars if you're new to
Brazilian sign language nice well in
terms of the app why Hugo why was the
Avatar designed the way it was and huger
the name when I was designing him I
wasn't really sure how he would look
like but I was pretty clear of what I
wanted him to represent right so we were
making this character there would be not
the mascot but the brother himself I
wanted him to have the mission of the
camp
and I wanted him to look friendly and
also credible because that's what we
were aiming for as a company right and
also I wanted him to be specific for
sign language communication so I gave
him a few characteristics like long
limbs and large hands and also like a
large face for facial expressions
because this is really really important
for communication in sign language and
that's where the name it was my wife to
name him I had picked this placeholder
name just at random so that I could name
the files in the the geometry and things
like that and she came up on there said
he doesn't look like it looks like a
Hugo when she said that it was pretty
obvious that she was right everybody
agreed and the name really stuck I love
the details that you have to think about
I mean that's impressive to think about
it in terms of the design of the
character itself the long limbs the
large hands the facial expressions these
are things people wouldn't normally
consider but you have to consider when
you're doing designed yeah and even like
the clothes that he's wearing was you
know we went through quite a few
iterations to get to something that
wasn't very formal but at the same time
it wasn't too casual and he has died but
not a suit I think we got it right that
sounds great
I'd love to get stuck in more into like
how the translation process is made
especially like geez I mean you kind of
hit it like you just dropped it in and I
was like wow that's amazing
in the the translation is not just the
hand expressions but also the facial
expressions as well so I'd love to hear
more about how that works
yes our facial expressions are really
important in sign language like there's
basically the difference between a
question I'm not sure body sl I'm
talking about Brazilian sign language
which I know for sure that the
difference between a question and an
affirmation so if you do the same signs
you don't do the facial expression you
can't be really sure if the person is
saying or asking it's almost like a turn
yes and also the the facial expression
are built in on the signs some signs
require your facial expressions for them
to work some signs are only facial
expressions it's hard to explain here
because people are not gonna have the
visual but hey but there are some signs
that are just official expression but
what's one that you would say that is a
facial expression that's a sign like
thief beside for thief in Brazilian sign
language is like this he's sticking his
tongue into the side of his mouth yeah
yeah this is like a discreet way to say
look there's a fee nice thing yeah tell
us more about how like technologically
this works I really want to hear about
how these translations are made okay the
translation happens in two steps and
they're quite distinct one of them is to
translate the oral language into what we
call gloss glossing is the process of
writing a language in another language
and that's required for sign language
because unfortunately there is no
official way to write in sign language
there are a couple of attempts to make
that to create symbols to represent the
position and handshape of signs but
there's nothing official yet and that's
one of the reasons why it's hard to find
data on sign language because it's
really hard to represent like we do with
our language with letters right the
first step is to convert oral language
like Portuguese to glass which is
written sign language and and then we
can convert the glass into science or
fingerspelling
to each we have our database of science
and we can swap each sign tag to an
animation and hand it back to the user
and whenever we don't have an assigned
with you what with what's actually done
in real life which is to finger spell
the word if deaf people come by a word
they have never seen before like Google
for instance they can fingerspell it the
finger spell goog and once they get
acquainted to it they come up with a
sign for it
so that's exactly what our transition
system does if we find a new word or a
proper noun like like a name we can
fingerspell it and if we know that
referring to that one specific person
like Barack Obama we can swap that for
the sign instead of fingerspelling I say
what's the sign for Google I'm not quite
sure we're not sure either but I'm sure
we will look it up and find out later so
okay where's their board that you wanted
to explain in terms of the way you
translate because I'm very curious
especially now with where things are at
with neural nets like how you're
building out the translation from being
able to read to have spoken and written
language translated into actual
animation yeah okay so the animation
process is really straightforward just
swap the ID by the animation or
fingerspell it but the hard part is
really to get the grammar right for sign
language because currently we are using
a statistical machine translation system
that is phrase based that's what we have
currently in production but what we
really would like you is to have a neuro
machine translation system implemented
especially because we have the
opportunity now with some tools that
Google has released in the past couple
of months to have this translation
system deployed to the device to the
end-user Google has this last as a full
summit they released tensorflow GS
which is a way to implement to do rap
inference on on the bread browser which
is amazing in training as well and
firebase which is our primary back end
also released a machine learning kit
which is also super promising like
there's many things that we would love
to do with it and when we nail that not
emotional translation system and if it's
light enough we can allow the user to do
translations offline which is something
that everybody dislike one of our top
requests for features when we first met
we were talking about how your group
went through the launchpad studio
program you were one of the initial
companies that went through this and
this of course is launchpad studio we
had a podcast on that at the beginning
of the year what kind of products and
services did it give
you access to that you've been able to
use in your company we were on the first
class of the launchpad studio and our
bootcamp was on January 2016 and it was
amazing like real really good I remember
that there were two things that became
really clear after that and those are
two meetings that we keep going back to
you and one of the things was when we
did a UX test with someone that had
never used the app before it sounds you
know really basic but we were able to
see like where people were really
struggling to find information that we
thought were really obvious and it's
really enlightening when you're able to
see someone that has never used your app
before trying to find the things that
you already know where they are and
you're not allowed to talk right so one
of the things that followed after that
was a redesign of the app so that things
would be even clearly defined and that
people that were arriving there for the
first time wouldn't have to look for
them as much and the other thing that
was really important for us in the
launch pad was that we've been asked
what was the product about like who was
it trying to help exactly is it a person
that uses the all our language as a
first language or is the deaf user and
the idea was that if our app doesn't do
translation from sign language to oral
language how is the deaf users are gonna
use it and are we trying to build a
translator or an Education Act because
those are two very different things like
if you're trying to build a translator
you can just go ahead and listen to the
mic like right away and if you're
building an education app what you want
to do is to access how much sign
language that person knows and to help
him or her get started with the first
basic signs that they're gonna learn so
we opted for being an Education Act
because we believe that that's what's
most important for us to do what are the
biggest challenges with sign language
sign language is really peculiar why
not many people know this but sign
language is really really different from
other kinds of conditions like blindness
or mobility impairment because sign
language creates a culture and that's
the main difference right because deaf
people experience life in a very
different manner than people that can
hear the life experience that they have
is primarily visual so everything comes
down to what is seen and that's why sign
language is really like a natural
language for them that's why sign
language feels more natural than any
other language for them the second
reason is that there's one concept which
is the concept of Deaf culture which is
really important to understand when you
say that someone is deaf with a
uppercase D it means that they're
culturally deaf it's not only they're
clinically deaf that it can't hear or
they maybe they can hear with the aid of
cochlear implants or hearing aids but
what that means is that they identify
with deaf culture they likely have that
friends and they enjoy what's called
deaf art and they are aware of deaf
history and there's a lot of there are
lots of cultural manifestations to that
and one other thing that deafness is
really peculiar is the fact that
sometimes deaf children struggle to
learn the first language and this is a
real real big problem because 90 to 95%
of deaf children are born from hearing
parents and that makes it really likely
that their children is the very first
deaf person that they ever met and it is
hard to learn sign language for someone
that came here it's really hard so it is
important for deaf parents to have help
when they are trying to learn sign
language you make tools available for
them so they can acquire sign language
or learn sign language as much as they
can to have a better communication with
their children there are a couple of
interesting stories we have about this
like
one of the things that really makes our
days when we get feedback from users and
they send us like emails and Facebook
messages saying that our app is helping
them have a better relationship with
their daughter for instance because they
have like a daughter that's ten years
old and she's deaf she goes to deaf
school and in school she can communicate
perfectly and has no problem whatsoever
but when she gets home she has no one to
talk to and you hear that there are
parents that are using our app to learn
sign language in their spare time
to be able to better communicate with
their daughter is like something that we
really value that that's why way back
then when we were deciding on which
business model to pursue we decided that
we would not want to charge for the app
like whatsoever it's not our intention
to charge you know five six ten dollars
to a parent that wants to learn sign
language so that they can communicate
with a kid or a friend that wants to
learning basic signs so that they can
say hello to a co-worker and things like
that so that's why we had the idea of
offering services to companies so that
companies can pay if they want to make
one of their channels available also in
sign language this is amazing a story
about it just your ethos around the
entire company it's it's phenomenal I
really would love to also just get stuck
a bit more into the technical side of
things I know you're very large firebase
users um why did you choose firebase
like what what gets you excited about
using that product our first server
version was done entire by me on ojs and
I coated the whole thing from scratch
and you know even though it's not that
hard to make a server user system with
log in log out you know reset password
and create account forms and things like
that it's not that hard I find it really
important to be able to have that
information really secure like you store
the Bester's the right way
and that's not that trivial like it's
really important to have security and to
have your app be stable and that's one
of the most amazing things about
firebase is that the keeps us coming
back to firebase is the fact that we can
create user accounts and login there are
third-party authentication systems like
really easily and reliably and also one
of the things that we didn't really
think that would benefit as much which
is a real-time database the fact that
you can receive updates from the
database directly but it's really
amazing like it really changes the
perception of the user when for instance
they know that someone is on their
website and they can see the dashboard
update instantly without having to
refresh the page that's that's something
that's really really helpful as well
there are other things in firebase that
gets really really you know excited
about it one of them is the fact that in
2016 they released the Google Club
functions which is amazing tool like not
having to manage servers is something
that's really valuable to us because
sometimes we do have huge spikes on
usage like when there is a big news
outlet you know makes a blog post about
us and we have like a huge spike on
translations and relying on called
functions for that and not having to
monitor instances is really helpful as
well so there are many things in
firebase that I really like for those
three are the most important I believe
great there are also other Google cloud
platform services that we are using that
are really helpful too okay one of the
hard things about making a translation
system for sign language is that data is
really hard to come by I know that ESL
it's it's not as hard as it is for
libres but to find data on Lieber is
really really hard it would be awesome
if we could do just like google
translator does which is use something
like the European Parliament corpora or
a database of translator websites where
you have references for sometimes two
sometimes three four different languages
and use that to feature translation
but with sign language we don't really
have that we had to create our own
corpus from from scratch or by text is
done on a tour that we created which
actually you know it's heavily inspired
by Google Translate community which is
the web app that you can contribute to
translations and we have a system kinda
like that but for sign language whether
you can also pick the signs you want or
determine if a certain tag is
fingerspelled
and that's how we we produce the data to
all so for our translation system how
much data do you have for training yeah
we have our core pieces around half a
million sentences and any using Google
Cloud form anything that how does that
all work okay so we use dataflow to
clean up and merge two databases that we
have with information on our by text
with Portuguese in Brazilian sign
language and we trained everything on
cloud ml which is also a huge huge deal
for us like cloud emails a godsend how
so
as I mentioned we have some quite long
sentences and we have a bunch of unknown
words like the name many people
translate their names in the app right
they want to say my name is you know
so-and-so and we have many unknown words
of names of entities and proper nouns
and our system can get really memory
intensive like it consumes a lot of
memory and it would be really hard to
train that on our hardware I have a
MacBook so it would be really hard to
train that on on Hardware on premise so
we've been using cloud imel's since the
beginning to iterate in to test new
versions of our translation a neuro
machine translation system and it's
working really really well it's it's
amazing well this is wonderful so one
question I have for you is you know I
know we were saying how it's focused on
Portuguese and Brazilian sign language
what are your future plans in terms of
sign language translation we have many
features that we would like to do on our
some of them on the short-term like
American Sign Language but some of them
are gonna take a little bit longer to
develop the technology for them American
Sign Language we would like to be done
by the end of the year but we have we're
closing around the funny right now and
it's taking a little bit longer than we
expected we have to run the numbers
against you to have a point of date for
when the ASL is gonna be ready so
American Sign Language is one that
you're targeting hopefully by the end of
the year depending on how things are
going with funding and other languages
other features that your you're
interested in pursuing one of the other
features that we really would love to
implement is doing the other way around
like currently we only do oral language
- sign language but we would love to do
sign language - oral language to be able
to use the device camera to convert
images to oral language that would be
something very big for us
agreed especially with the way machine
learning is evolving from object
identification and other classification
and predictive tooling around image
analysis this is wonderful these you
know if people out there are interested
in contributing to your company and
contributing to the product what are
ways that they can get involved okay I
thought of three things that might be
interesting what if that you know ASL or
you represent an institution that deals
with ASL you can get in touch with us to
see how we can either come up with a
partnership to help improve our ASL
translation system so you can get in
touch with me on Twitter at th a de u L
u Z and also if you're aware if your
data scientists in you're aware of
language labeled or unlabeled data sets
for ASL that are open you can send their
link to me because I'm I'm pretty sure
there are quite a few data sets that I'm
not aware of yet on yourself and I'm
looking for them collecting them to know
exactly which ones we can use to speed
up the process of coming up with data
and if you're just curious about sign
language and would love to hear from us
when we released the ASL version of her
app you can go to Hancock dot Amy - ASL
and sign up to your newsletter there and
you're gonna be the first one to know
when we have the app ready for English
in American Sign Language
well this is great thank you so much
that is for joining us and for sharing
about hand talk about Hugo and you'd
mentioned it's available on Google Play
so thank you very much yeah thanks so
much okay thank you guys
Thank You fati us again for coming on
the podcast I'm so glad we were able to
talk about what hand talk is built and
what you're working on and where that's
going
I love these types of tools because I
love how they are breaking down more and
more communication barriers that's
exciting to me in terms of what
technology has the potential for so
alright mark what does a go developer
need to know about GCP what doesn't it
go developer need to know about GCP know
this is a great question we wanted to
highlight this because yeah we had
another teammate I think it's like
teammate a Palooza but I think we're
just talking about how amazing yeah how
amazing and my teammates are you know
Compton developer advocate for girl
Google cloud wrote a really amazing
article talking about exactly these
types of things and basically the
choices that you have in terms of where
you might want to host your code so
maybe you might want to put it on GCE
compute engine maybe you want to put it
on kubernetes engine maybe you want to
put it on App Engine even sort of goes
and has a look at cloud functions
talking about the unofficial and
unsupported native go runtime that
exists it's a nice overview of GCP but
from a go perspective yeah it's really
great so there's lots of options go
through a lot of the pros and cons he
even talked about machine learning API
is and how you can use that Surigao as
well it's it's worth a read yeah all
right mark you're going to be speaking
anywhere anytime soon yeah so I'm gonna
be presenting at the kubernetes
community meeting which i think is
tomorrow based on the day this comes out
in the morning Pacific time in the US
they let's get the time zones right yeah
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes that's online so anyone can come
in and listen I'm gonna be talking about
a ganas and then later this week I'm
getting on a plane going to Denmark I'm
gonna go hang out with our unity friends
they've got a hack week that I'm gonna
go play with and so expect lots of
tweets and social stuff to come out of
that Copenhagen's fund especially for
food mmm I love the food there what are
you doing i while your way will be going
to speak at an
that the women in machine learning a
data science and PI ladies are joint
organizing called paths to data science
and so will include the meetup link in
the show notes and that's on Tuesday the
26 and then I'm speaking at Stanford at
the AI for all it's like a technology
camp for those who are more in the high
school space and so that is on June 28
that I will be speaking there when you
say technology camp is that like in
tents and stuff technology to me seems
like fun and going to a camp it's like I
think it's almost like band camp ok
technology camp I've done that before
I've done like go out in the bush with
like tents and dorms nice it's not tents
now no definitely not tents but it's all
about learning cool and understanding
and exposing text especially to people
who are younger trying to get into the
space awesome
well Melanie thank you so much for
joining me for yet another podcast this
week thank you Mark I thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
you